und jetzt bei mir ein mann den man in
der korona krise gar nicht mehr erklären
muss karl lauterbach gesundheitsexperte
der spd er dauert aber auch an sie die
frage brauchen wir eine impfpflicht für
schulen kindergärten und für ähnliche
einrichtungen ich glaube dass für eine
solche pflicht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht benötigen es kann durchaus sein
dass wir zu einer impfpflicht kommen
müssen beispielsweise für einrichtungen
wo menschen gepflegt werden oder
behandelt werden weil sie eben besonders
vollen rabl sind aber ferne impfpflicht
also in schulen oder kindergärten sich
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht die
veranlassung wir haben gerade eine
relativ heftige debatte im deutschen
bundestag erlebt es ging um die
verlängerung der epidemischen lage die
union sagt ganz klar das ist ein fehler
die auslaufen zu lassen die ampel der
sie angehören sagt die kann man
auslaufen lassen die union sagt wir
brauchen weiterhin die möglichkeit auch
für regionale oder für flächendeckende
lockdown liegt die union richtig ich
glaube dass es hier also er ist zu sagen
dass das für heute vorgelegt haben als
ampel sieht den instrumentenkasten vor
der weitergeht dass das was wir bisher
haben die frage die von der union
aufgeworfen wurde brauchen wir noch eine
flächendeckende lockdown oder die
möglichkeit dafür und da sagen uns die
juristen dass das einfach rechtlich
nicht mehr ginge ich glaube dass es auch
medizin nicht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht notwendig ist wenn wir den
instrumentenkasten den wir heute
beschlossen haben konsequent umsetzen
aber wie dem auch immer sei wenn es so
richtig nicht geht und das ist was mir
immer wieder vorgetragen wird ich bin
kein jurist dann können wir es auch
nicht weitermachen jetzt hoffen sich
nachher wieder 16 ministerpräsidenten
mit einer geschäftsführenden
bundeskanzlerin gibt es irgendetwas was
da heute beschlossen werden kann was die
ministerpräsidenten nicht links hätten
tun können es ist in der tat richtig
dass also alles hätte schon beschlossen
werden können und vieles hätte
beschlossen werden müssen somit wir sind
also viel zu spät und ich habe eben auch
in meiner kurzen also rede gesagt dass
die also ministerpräsidenten die jetzt
klagen dass das gesetz nicht weit genug
ging das bestehende gesetz nicht
ausreichend genutzt hat wir sind ohne
not in eine aus meiner sicht
katastrophale lage gekommen wir haben
derzeit mit der dunkelziffer weit über
hunderttausend neue fälle pro tag wir
haben jeden tag also das äquivalent
eines flugzeugabsturzes an toten wir
haben sehr viele menschen die chronisch
kranke die lage hätte so nicht
eskalieren dürfen und wir müssen jetzt
schauen was wir noch retten können für
den satz mit dem flugzeugabsturz unter
den toten ist markus söder ich glaube
vor ziemlich genau einem jahr mal heftig
gescholten worden wollen sie den so
stehen lassen ist das so ja es ist so
also im durchschnitt sterben im moment
so viele menschen wie also sterben
würden werden ein flugzeugabsturz und
ich habe vor einem jahr den gleichen
satz ebenfalls verwendet unabhängig von
markus söder satz ist nicht falsch nur
weil denn auch markus söder verwendet es
gab heute die kurzintervention oder rede
eines afg abgeordneten von der tribüne
von stiebert heißt er glaube ich die da
oben auf der tribüne sein muss weil er
nicht geimpfte sie haben ihn mit dafür
verantwortlich macht andere kollegen
auch dass menschen sterben ist dass der
umgangston denen man im parlament fliegt
stehen sie dazu ich stehe auf jeden fall
dazu also der umgangston darf ja nicht
beleidigend oder was auch immer sein
aber werden jeder kollege aufsteht vor
laufenden kameras und sagt dass die
impfung mehr schadet als die krankheit
dann gibt es leute die das glauben die
sich dann nicht impfen lassen und
möglicherweise sterben zumindest das
sachlich richtig und ich stehe
selbstverständlich dazu sonst hätte ich
das nicht gesagt vielen dank für das
gespräch dann ging